your husband's a chef which is so great
I mean especially during this time you
sold a TV show I don't know who - who he
is gonna teach you how to cook they
reached out and we're like do you guys
feel like making a cooking show I was
like I don't know how to cook at all
there well he could teach you and I was
like all right and they were like we'll
give you some money and also they agreed
to donate 50k to the Middle Way house
and to the Immokalee coalition and the
fair food project so the Food Network
you don't agreed to do that and and so
we were like let's do it now are you
gonna make a lot of jokes while he's
teaching you to cook or are you gonna
take it seriously I mean we already shot
it like we shot the first season no I
make jokes the whole timing it's just us
being ourselves so I'm like trashing him
and and you know and he's like
belittling me and like we're just we
both have like learning disabilities so
we get like we lose focus and then what
you know it's it's then we fight it's
just like it's ridiculous and I make
drinks and and then we're kind of like
half in the bag and but I am learning
how to cook which is so cool because I
really didn't didn't really know if I
watched the show while it's entertaining
I am actually going to learn how to cook
something it's not you're not going to
blow off that aspect of it right right
yeah see I think that's good cuz I don't
know how to make like people come over
and they want to mix drink I don't know
how to [ __ ] make a mix drink I don't
yeah so it's like but I do want to know
how to do it yeah I bartended for like
10 years so I know how to do that and I
don't think the Food Network knew that
but it's cool so I can like just kind of
share little like hacks from bartending
I don't know I hope it's good I mean we
literally they were like do you want to
do this we shot it ourselves our nanny
is the camera person well and then we
should we shot it when gene was taking
his nap so he wakes up guess what he's
on the show